unser oma hat immer gesagt kompromiss
wirft immer schön wie kann man sowas
erzählte emotionen ins spiel kommen
jetzt hat uns sehr überrascht
verständnislos bin nicht vorkommen
verständnis ein indiskutables thema kwan
schieber an sich nur weil ich so nicht
vermutet hätte
[Musik]
nicht
ja der letzte konservative am tisch so
habe ich mich gefühlt ob er wirklich
konservativ ist wenn er aktiviert oder
rechts ist und ich glaube die spd kommt
irgendwo um die 22 25 prozent
tatsächlich sind die sozialen medien
mittlerweile die orte in denen sich die
wahlen entscheiden werden
40 jahre jugend mein name ist lisa ich
bin 31
my name is a wir sind sechs leute aus
essen werden alle eine andere parteien
diskutieren über alle möglichen themen
zu wollen über instagram ja da gibt es
dann immer so einen kleinen
schlagabtausch untereinander digital
weil wir ja jeder eine andere partei
wählen werden und sind dann so
eine kleine bundestagsdebatte aber wir
sind heute morgen leute kommen politiker
ja das ist ein wahnsinnig interessant
das projekt die phoenix wallstraße das
findet dass bei instagram oder auch fürs
fernsehen
das fing damit an dass wir die
kandidaten alle kennen lernen bei einem
gemeinsamen abendessen man geht der
querschnitt der bevölkerung und das sind
alles menschen die
normalerweise wahrscheinlich auf
irgendwelchen facebook kanälen sich dann
irgendwie beschimpfen würden und man
sitzt da gemeinsam und verbringt einen
abend zusammen
es ist super wichtig dass wir unsere
klimaziele erreichen wir müssen deshalb
nur sozialverträglich gestaltet
natürlich dass das ziel ist es aber egal
aus welchen wohl wir gehen richtung
klimaneutralität das ist gut für uns
alle
ich sehe das noch nicht so wir haben
aktuell jetzt in kanada
46 grad und machen immer noch eine
absolut wie ich finde
mutlose politik ich frage mich woran
liegt das menschengemachte klimawandel
ist schon interessant wie will ich jetzt
feststellen welcher anteil des
klimawandels menschen gemacht ist zieht
sich meiner kenntnis wie das diskutieren
es gibt da die regel 94 prozent und 6
prozent und dann werden die zahlen
miteinander multipliziert das sind ja
alles
wissenschaftliche ausarbeitung von
leuten die davon leben das ist ja ganz
klar wie bei allen dingen wie bei allen
ausarbeitungen die in auftrag gegeben
werden da kommt das aus bei jedem
gutachter kommt das sein was der
auftraggeber vorgibt das problem ist
natürlich auch mit den kohlekraftwerken
beispielsweise um das ganze ab zustand
jetzt plant eures 2038
es ist schwierig es gibt andere parteien
ich möchte jetzt kein vergleich es gibt
andere parteien die sagen okay wurden
das alles sofort stoppen wir brauchen
aber mehr autos und weniger co2
ausstoßen die frage ist auch ein buch
kommt der strom her
ich bin also ohne vater aufgewachsen
mit meiner schwester also meiner
halbschwester und meine schwester ist
ein ganz anderer mensch hat sich um
meine schwester lebt vegan und
der lebt der ökonomisch und nachhaltig
würde ich sagen und die wird natürlich
dann die grün- und da gibt es ab und zu
konflikten zwischen uns glauben
die liebliche standard wählerin bei mir
gibt es einfach die meisten
übereinstimmung mit der cdu ich vertraue
der cdu an dass sie hat nächsten jahres
verändern können beziehungsweise danach
steht und denke auch dass aktuell andere
parteien wie beispielsweise die grünen
mode sind ja ich will die cdu aber ich
finde dass die cdu in sachen klimaschutz
nachholbedarf hat wie bewegen und
service packs klimaschutz in die
richtige richtung denn noch viel zu
lange seien und mit viel zu wenig
geplanten ziel für die für die nächsten
jahr es geht tatsächlich um den erhalt
unserer lebensgrundlage also es geht
darum das ist ohne unsere
lebensgrundlage wird es keine wirtschaft
geben es wird kein schutz für sozial
schwächere geben es wird keine bildung
mehr geben es wird halt einfach keine
menschen mehr geben und das ist es worum
es bei dem thema klimawandel geht die 20
540 ist ein schönes ziel
dieses pariser klimaabkommen bis dahin
umzusetzen ich glaube aber dass wir
jetzt deutschland mehr erreichen können
dass man auch sagen kann wir schauen
vielleicht bis 2042 oder bis 2040 oder
wir machen uns vielleicht noch mal zehn
prozent co2 weniger ich glaube wenn man
an den richtigen stellschrauben dreht
und wirtschaft politik alles irgendwie
in einer hand spielt dass wir da mehr
erreichen können als das was jetzt in
den wahlprogrammen drin steht das ist
keine frage wenn man den co2 ausstoß
bekämpfen sind sie nicht unbedingt die
flugzeuge sondern die großen schiffe ein
großes containerschiff hat ja so viel
aus wie die ganzen deutschen autos
bleiben ja
ich sitze heute auf gepackten koffer
denn ich fliege nach mallorca
wir besuchen dort verwandtschaft und ich
gehöre wie alle anderen auch zu den
normalsterblichen die für die ferien nur
ein begrenztes zeitliches kontingent
haben als feststand boogie hinfliegen
habe ich zwei tage lang recherchiert und
irgendwann komplett ändern auf diesen
flug gebucht und jetzt mache ich mich
klar und wahllos was muss ich dir hören
ist schlägt in urlaub und das als grüne
dass mit euren klimaziel zu vereinbaren
ist dieses typische mit dem finger auf
grüne zeigen und sagen ihr macht das
aber nicht perfekt und da finde ich hat
man die grün nicht verstanden weil es
den grünen nicht darum geht dass alle
leute alles perfekt machen und ihr leben
komplett auf links drehen sondern dass
jeder den beitrag den er dazu leisten
kann und bereit ist zu leisten leistet
und das tue ich im grünen finger selbst
am meisten
das ist ja auch wieder faktencheck habe
ich sofort ich habe sofort stehen sie
habe irgendwann hätten mit dem eis und
sind mal eben weg vor sich frühstück bei
tiffany ich habe ja nichts dagegen diese
unterstützen dass etliche auf wie
verrückt
[Musik]
im juni hatte die cdu in den umfragen
noch doppelt so viel wie die spd und die
grünen sind da von ihrem höhenflug
runter gekommen und haben ordentlich
verloren und eigentlich schien zu
sommerbeginn noch alles ganz ganz klar
fußball
europameisterschaft
achtelfinal spiel england gegen
deutschland
die mannschaft dass sie sich nicht
nehmen lassen zum ersten und auch zum
letzten mal in diesem turnier auf die
knie zu gehen und kultivierter mensch
wird das recht von schwulen und lesben
bestreiten erregenden vorstellungen der
freien glücklich zu leben das kann nicht
heißen dass jetzt jeder vor der
regenbogenflagge salutieren muss die
farben unseres landes sind immer noch
schwarz rot gold
also ich würde auch nicht vor der
schwarz rot goldenen fahne salutieren
niemand muss vor einer regenbogenflagge
salutieren niemand muss vor der
deutschland frage salutieren und es sind
zwei unterschiedliche flaggen das eine
ist eine frage einer bewegung das andere
ist eine frage einer nation wo ist da
der zusammenhang rassismus und hass
gegen die quere community haben im
fußball und haben auf der ganzen welt
nichts verloren und deswegen ist es
immer wieder gut ein zeichen zu setzen
gegen hass
grundsätzlich der kniefall war
überflüssig und auch die
regenbogenfahnen ist überflüssig weil in
deutschland ist aus meiner sicht kein
thema und die homosexuellen die ich
kenne und wir haben ja welche in der
partei die in obersten
führungspositionen sind die wollen dann
eigentlich nicht wir wollen nicht dass
das so nach vorne gehoben wird man
erreicht das gegenteil dass hier leute
mit dem kopf schütteln was soll das
jetzt und warum müssen die jetzt auf die
knie geht ja das ist einfach nur eine
provokation den leuten die eben denken
wir wohl mal ein bisschen normal leben
gerade im bereich
diskriminierung die fdm sehr auf der
linie
sobald andere menschen sie dafür
sensibilisieren wollen dass das direkt
gesellschaftlicher zwang und jeder muss
denn dann wird ja auch häufig
vorgeworfen oder jeder muss mit
regenbogenfarben herumlaufen aber das
ist ja gar nicht das ziel das ziel ist
einfach dass man an die menschen
appelliert es ist egal woher du kommst
wenn du liebst wie du aussiehst seid
einfach respektvoll wenn man dann halt
sagt ja wir möchten jetzt hier im
fußballstadion in regenbogenfarben
machen ja dann sollen sie es bitte
machen wenn dann die uefa damals gesagt
hat das ist aber doch jetzt irgendwie
ein politisches statement dann dürften
auch keine wm nach katar vergeben oder
so ist auch ein politisches statement
darüber hinaus werden in einigen monaten
die fußball weltmeisterschaft in einem
land stattfinden wo man für
homosexualität fünf oder mehr jahre ins
gefängnis kommen fußball auch in katar
zu machen
mit menschenrechtsverletzungen also
finde ich persönlich natürlich kaka
[Musik]
andreas heute sehr battle dollar stärke
und ich habe mich gefragt wie du zu dem
thema mindestlohn stehst ja hallo visa
ich bin gegen den mindestlohn ganz klar
weil ich als ehemalige geschäftsführer
eines mittelständischen unternehmens mit
100 mitarbeitern immer noch der meinung
bin dass das der tarifautonomie club
liegt das heißt außerdem eine schwächung
der gewerkschaften zufolge und ich weiß
nicht ob das so gut findet grundsätzlich
bin ich natürlich einfach für den
mindestlohn und vor allem dass dieser
natürlich auch erhöht wird ich komme
eigentlich aus der castoren ich bin
gelernte köchin und ich glaube dass ich
das für vor einigen gastronomen aber
schwierig gestaltet wenn die mehr zahlen
müssen müssen natürlich auch die preise
erhöhen es kommen natürlich ist auch die
branche an und ich glaube dass für
einige schwierig gestalten würde ich
finde es super super wichtig die
menschen die wirklich in unserer
gesellschaft eher unten stehen
so abzusichern dass sie
zumindest einen mindestlohn bekommen es
ist ja das mindeste wie ich schon in
diesem wort heißt seit 2005 auch eben
ohne eine abgeschlossene ausbildung der
mindestlohn gezahlt werden muss
entscheiden sich viele junge leute gegen
eine ausbildung weil die
ausbildungsvergütung wesentlich geringer
ist als der mindestlohn so eine sache
wie der mindestlohn ja ist sicherlich
nötig den anzuheben ich finde auch zwölf
euro 50 als mindestlohn zu wenig von mir
aus könnte jeder 15 16 euro oder so
einer stunde verdienen
weil arbeit ja muss einfach
wertgeschätzt werden und dass alle auf
dem balkon stehen und klatschen davon
hat einen altenpfleger oder eine
kassiererin kein cent mehr im
portemonnaie also da muss was passieren
weil gerade die teilzeit angestellten
die sind mit sicherheit jetzt schon
vorprogrammiert halten ja im rentenalter
in der altersarmut zu landen
das ist meine heimat ich bin hier
geboren ich bin hier aufgewachsen meine
mutter war frisörin
musst du auch nebenbei arbeiten weil sie
mit dem geld ausgekommen ist
und mein vater werkzeugmacher also bei
uns in der familie waren arbeiter es
waren keine
stadt also es hat nie an einer familie
studiert vorher
deswegen liegt es vielleicht auch
formell man wird sicherlich auch vom
elternhaus manchmal geprägt welche
partei man welt die größte
herausforderung meiner meinung nach für
mich mal eine generation wahrscheinlich
auch noch für folgende generationen ist
sicherlich die altersarmut viele kriegen
ja jetzt schon dem rentenbescheid sein
so mein gott wie soll ich mit dem geld
auskommen da wird finde ich viel zu
wenig auch im moment von der politik für
getan altersarmut ist nach wie vor ein
wichtiges thema was auch in diesem
wahlkampf finde ich zu kurz kommt weil
einfach viele leute die 45 oder 7 40
jahre gearbeitet haben nachher stempeln
müssen oder noch flaschensammeln noch
irgendwie tabletten ausfahren wie auch
immer also weiter arbeiten müssen weil
sich einfach sonst nichts leisten können
und das darf einfach nicht sein wir sind
ein reiches land wir sollten ja in der
lage sein den leuten so viel rente
auszuzahlen dass sie halt auch wenn sie
45 über 7 40 jahre gearbeitet haben
davon leben können ich denke viele
personen die die linken wählen sind halt
auch zum beispiel in der pflege tätig
und da kann man nicht durch bauern bis
ende 60 das geht nicht und natürlich ist
es dann auch für diese person
erstrebenswert das rentenalter zu senken
[Musik]
laut einer aktuellen meldung ist der
anteil junger menschen in deutschland
auf dem tiefstand die generation z die
15 bis 24 jährigen beträgt in
deutschland gerade mal 10,1 prozent ich
finde es wäre super wenn das wahlalter
auf 16 heruntergesetzt wird in
deutschland haben wir viel mehr menschen
die über 60 sind zum beispiel die
beeinflussen die war ja viel mehr als
zum beispiel die jüngeren generation es
werden ein kleiner ausgleich nochmals
wegen wenn ich das super die fdp hat
außerdem im letzten herbst bei ihrer bei
ihrem bundesparteitag
das wahlrecht ab 16 beschlossen meiner
meinung nach super wichtige progressive
idee damit 16 und 17 jährige auch wegen
können und damit ihre interessen nicht
nur durch demos und irgendwelche anderem
aktionen vertreten werden sondern auch
tatsächlich durch eine stimme ich habe
hier die liste von der fdp kennen
gelernt wahnsinnig jungen gerade mal 18
jahre und ich habe in diesem abend essen
gesessen und gedacht wow so eine
aufgeklärte abgeklärte
frische jugend haben wir hier noch die
ja gegen diesen pessimismus angesprochen
hat hoch informiert war super gebildet
war ich würde sogar so weit gehen ich
heiße eine volljährigkeit ab 16 auch für
sehr sinnvoll auch wenn man dann
geschäftsfähig ist um dann auch quasi
konsequent zu argumentieren zusammen mit
dem wahlrecht sind gerade aus der
wallstraße sehe ich ja dass die jüngeren
als glaubt
von der fdp das mädel ist glaube ich 18
da sieht man natürlich dass sogar das so
die grenze ist glaube ich
also das ist jetzt so eine typische
ruhrpott geschichte ich hatte jetzt das
privileg ich kann studieren mein vater
war die erste generation in unserer
familie die studiert hat und das war
damals noch ein riesending
mein
großvater bearbeiter und der hat mein
vater schon immer gesagt es ist nicht
schlimm wenn du nicht promoviert ist
dann wie es weiter arbeiten ist trotzdem
ein guter mensch mich nervt in
deutschland dass die eigenen bildungs
und berufserfolg immer noch an das
eigene elternhaus gekoppelt sind die
größte herausforderung
meiner generation ist die herstellung
einer generation recht ich hoffe meine
zukünftigen kinder und enkel ich glaube
und 16 ist man noch nicht reif genug um
zu werden ich denke dass viele dann
vielleicht zu jux und dollerei wählen
gehen und irgendeinen mist gehen wovon
sie überhaupt keine ahnung haben
eventuell ich weiß es nicht ich finde
das so wie es in ordnung ich finde nicht
dass es weiter herunter gestuft werden
sollte auf einmal leute jetzt 16 gehen
dürfen gerade in dieser informations
gesellschaft in der wir heute leben mit
internet und reisen und bildung dass die
menschen viel fitter sind als wir und
ich finde ein wahlrecht mit 16 ist ist
mega angebracht so in gegenden mit hohem
migrationshintergrund wo die leute mit
16 glaube ich wissen wir gerade auf den
nummer nummer eins rapper irgendwie ist
aber wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal zu
wissen wir aktueller bundeskanzlers
also das ist halt der die gegend in der
der ich lebe deswegen glaube ich dass
viele jugendliche einfach noch nicht so
weit sind es gibt auch leute die sind 20
30 40 was weiß ich wo ich auch sagen
würde wir sind doch nicht reif zum
wählen das zweite bundesland eine
schlechte idee erstmal ist 18 auch noch
sehr jung ja dass man nicht alles weiß
und zwar würde das nur den linken
parteien helfen das also von mir
interessen das lager verlässt ganz klar
auszuschließen
ja ich komme aus essen schlafen essen
geworden und die meiste zeit auch in
essen gelebt und ich bin von haus aus
diplom in dünne und jetzt als
niederlassungsleiter für einen großen
mittelständischen anlagenbauer
international tätig ja drei
kindermädchen junge junge leider bin ich
geschehen und meine eltern die sind
leider den letzten beiden jahren
verstorben
mein vater obersteiger entsprechend auf
jetzt kirchen auf der schachtanlage
konsolidierung da hat er großen wert
darauf gelegt und meine mutter hatte
muss nur ganz traditionell gemacht war
chefsekretärin aber nach der hochzeit
hat sie nie wieder außerhalb der familie
gearbeitet
im juli haben sich die zahlen ja im
prinzip erst mal gar nicht geändert der
wahlkampf dümpelte so vor sich hin
mit konkreten team ist da noch keine
partei so wirklich durchgedrungen
[Musik]
was hältst du von
ihren ärzten merkel sagte dazu das
merken uns sozusagen fassen wird ich
hoffe einfach dass vielleicht auch
wirklich mal wieder ein bisschen mehr
erklärt wird warum wird irgendwas
gemacht und nicht einfach so
problem ausgesessen werden also das
glaube ich so ihre große große kunst
einfach nichts zu sagen ganz klar an
nummer 16 jahre ganz furchtbar
gleichzeitig kann erklären und setzten
ausgesessen ganz furchtbar weil ich von
vielen diesen entscheidungen auch
persönlich persönlich und beruflich
getroffen wurde ja bei insolvenz der mit
100 leuten auf unsere energiepolitik ich
habe dreimal die firma neu ausgerichtet
und verschiedene richtungen aber ich
muss wieder das muss ich wieder zu einer
bisschen konservativen politik kommen
nicht nur frau merkel uns kommst du und
ich war
eigentlich als wieder eine
bundeskanzlerin war es war die erste
bundeskanzlerin hast du frau die erst
noch genau so und das war super
besonderes vor allen dingen für mich in
dem alltag
ich will mit meinen beiden eltern
aufgewachsen ich habe noch zwei jüngere
geschwister
wir haben immer hier in frohnhausen
gelebt ich werde die linken weil sie
am besten zu meinen moralischen
ansichten passen also ein klima ist
natürlich ein thema ganz klar
bildung ist ein ganz klares thema für
mich soziale gerechtigkeit
das sind so ich denke es ist meine
hauptthemen ich habe auch schon mal
darüber nachgedacht zum beispiel die
grünen zu wählen
habe dann aber noch mal geschaut und bin
dann eindeutig wieder bei den linken
gelandet mich nervt dass wir in 72
jahren grundgesetz noch immer nur auf
papier gleichberechtigt und
gleichgestellt sind aber nicht in der
realität eine frau in dieser position zu
sehen macht gut macht mut gibt auch
jungen mädchen
teenagern also weiblichen teenagern noch
mal so eine perspektive
wo kann ich überall hin wo kann ich
überall hin als frau apropos bei
annalena baerbock ich finde die
sympathisch ich finde die fachlich immer
vorbereitet ich finde ich kann sehr gut
reden sie ist ein super vogel die hat
noch nie eine frau in diesem alter und
also
ich finde sie toll
wenn ich mit ihr habe ich nur den banken
verändert das sind ja welten nee ich
würde seine sind anders welten ist der
fall schon los anders aber egal wer das
land irgendwie ab september regieren
wird bitte keine 16 jahre mehr
was sollte man generell finde ich
festlegen dass sowie in anderen ländern
wie den usa also man nach zwei
legislaturen irgendwie sagt ich sage
jetzt ist damit der nächste mal
[Musik]
viele menschen im westen der republik
kämpfen gerade mit den folgen der
schlimmsten überflutungs katastrophen
der letzten jahre umso erschütterter bin
ich oder geradezu sprachlos wenn ich
sehe dass unsere noch-ministerpräsident
armin laschet der gleichzeitig der
kanzlerkandidat der cdu ist im
hintergrund einer rede von unserem
bundespräsidenten frank walter
steinmeier irgendwelche späßchen macht
bobadilla sich köstlich amüsiert mit
irgendwelchen leuten also dem fehlt doch
komplett die empathie
da werde ich fuchsteufelswild also gehe
ich gar nichts mehr zu sagen eigentlich
ja grundsätzlich gebe ich erstmal recht
und solch einer situation ist natürlich
nicht schön aus sie gelacht haben
dennoch finde ich das alles total
überzogen man weiß doch gar nicht was in
diesem land passiert ist warum die
gelacht haben und ich finde einfach so
eine momentaufnahme
nicht fair macht man einfach nicht
für das amt für das er sich bewirbt
macht man das nicht
dass meine meinung und da darf sowas
auch nicht passieren so unprofessionell
und wir können keinen professionellen
kanzler gebrauchen ich glaube auch nicht
dass die sich gedanken darüber gemacht
haben dass die im hintergrund eine
solche große rolle spielen und das hat
auch glaube ich nichts damit zu tun dass
der laschet wegen so etwas so eine
situation nicht ernst nimmt und man
sollte auch einfach mal die kirche im
dorf lassen daran noch nie tragbar
armin laschet
als der aufgestellt wurde habe ich mich
eigentlich als grüne gefreut weil armin
laschet ist das beste was mir als grüne
passieren würde weil würde weil er
eigentlich diese also ich muss jetzt
wirklich harte worte verwenden aber
diese inkompetenz der cdu flug war für
mich auf den punkt bringt ich denke
scholz steht so gut da
weil am nacht hat den wahlkampf für die
spd gemacht ich glaube durch laschet hat
die spd wirklich sehr viel zulauf
bekommen
ich denke ja menschen die vielleicht
vorher die cdu wählen wollten will jetzt
doch spd und ein teil wahrscheinlich
auch auf die
[Musik]
das rennen ist tatsächlich wieder
spannend geworden während sich bei den
umfragewerten ja die vergangenen monate
nicht allzu viel getan hat ist jetzt
wieder bewegung drin haben andererseits
dann die cdu und die grünen prozente
verloren und andererseits die spd noch
mal so ordentlich zugelegt da gab es
dann so erste gedankenspiele dass es für
schwarz grün nicht mehr reichen könnte
sondern man nochmal jamaika versuchen
muss
wir sind jetzt im kroatien urlaub und
irgendwie muss man schon feststellen
dass es hier scheinbar kein corona gibt
wenn man sich mal hier so ein bisschen
umschaut ich weiß nicht ob man gut sieht
aber die restaurants alle sind voll die
innenstadt ist voll die ganze promenade
ist voll und keiner trägt mundschutz
keiner hält sich ein abstände in den
restaurants linien wo irgendwie weniger
tisches werden tische zusammengestellt
das in zehn fünfzehn leute an einem
tisch also und könnte man hier gibt es
einfach kein corona die infektionszahlen
sind ungefähr wie in deutschland aber
irgendwie sieht man es hier deutlich
lockerer und da frage ich mich schon ob
wir in deutschland nicht alles irgendwie
doch ein bisschen zu sehr reglementieren
jahr die tun viel dafür dass es ganz da
nicht ausartet dennoch denke ich sind
die lok downs und angebracht gewesen
dann viele menschen natürlich der
selbständige menschen haben ihr leben
verloren alles verloren haben keine
unterstützung bekommen oder zu spät das
hätte alles ganz anders ablaufen können
vielleicht hätte man auch die grenzen
hört jetzt hat an aber die grenzen
vielleicht früher zumachen können
früher härtere einreisebeschränkungen
[Musik]
festlegen können das war am anfang alles
sehr schwammig ich glaube wir haben
während der pandemie häufig gesehen dass
dieses misstrauen gegenüber dem markt
ich will jetzt nicht sagen unbegründet
ist aber dass mal ist in deutschland ein
bisschen zurückschrauben könnten wir
haben auch bei den schnelltest gesehen
das gesundheitsministerium also der
staat war teilweise unfähig netz schnell
zur verfügung zu stellen währenddessen
haben unternehmen wie audi rossmann dm
die schon wochen für sobald sie es
angeboten was ich auch
unglaublich fand war wie die familien im
stich gelassen wurden und ich bin ja
selber betroffen ja also es wurde an
alle gedacht aber nur nicht an
diejenigen die diesen staat stützen
aufrechterhalten und täglich arbeiten
gehen ich hatte sehr das gefühl dass
studierende während der pandemie sehr
alleine gelassen wurden man hat als
student aktuell einfach sehr wenig
planungssicherheit weil man in der regel
ein paar wochen vor dem semester
bescheid kriegt ob das jetzt online
stattfindet ob s hybrid stattfindet ob
es im präsenz stattfindet das sind
einfach sehr schwierige
rahmenbedingungen
ich hatte manchmal das gefühl dass es
irgendwie so ein bisschen stimmungsmache
auch war und das nicht unbedingt auf die
ärzte und ups wurden auf die
krankenhäuser gehört wurde auf die
menschen in der pflege es fehlt total
die erfahrungswerte irgendwie deswegen
war es halt immer so ein bisschen try
and error habe ich in manchen bereichen
gedacht wenn man aber sieht wo wir
international im moment stehen geht es
uns eigentlich ganz gut also wir dürfen
wieder zumindest wenn sie geimpft und
genesen sind dürfen wir einiges wieder
machen
ich glaube es hätte deutlich schlimmer
ausgehen können ja hallo zum thema
impfen ist es bei mir so dass ich
bereits zweifach geimpft bin und ich
selber bin gegen eine impfpflicht ich
finde das thema ist ein sehr
persönliches thema und ich denke jede
person sollte sich wirklich einfach
darüber informieren bei guten quellen
informieren und daraufhin entscheiden ob
sie sich impfen lassen möchte oder nicht
genauso wie bei allen anderen impfungen
es gibt ich darf nicht dass ich das
könnte schon mal weg vom fenster also
beim hausarzt der ihn fällen ist hat mir
davon abgeraten weil ich hoch als er
gespielt auf diese zusatzstoffe für die
athleten sind also noch nicht mal auch
dass dieses
dings punkt da ja also insofern ist ja
für mich keine frage aber ich glaube ich
musste mich ja nicht damit
auseinandersetzen aber deswegen jawala
test aber ich glaube dass ich das nicht
hätte auch nicht machen würde ich bin
noch nicht voll überzeugt dass ich das
für mich gefährlich ist
ich vertraue auf mein immunsystem und
fällig ganz klar statistik gibt mir
recht habe ich hab auch noch ein
semester statistik des
maschinenbaustudiums was ich auch
wichtig finde ist dass es keinen
indirekten impfzwang gibt dass man zum
beispiel nur noch arbeiten gehen kann
wenn man sie impft ist das ist für mich
in direkter impfzwang ich war zwei
wochen urlaub wir waren eine frankreich
niederlande ich musste zu einer reise
und test machen dann muss ich wieder
eine niederlage das machen in frankreich
und ist machen dann braucht mit dem
restaurant wieder am testergebnis und
das einfache sehr viel durch gesagt habe
okay ich habe keine lust mehr ich lasse
mich jetzt nicht impfen nicht für mich
weil ich sorge habe okay in meinem alter
werde ich schwer krank oder hatte ich
stecke trotz natürlich auch andere
menschen an bin ich gebe ich bin dennoch
wenn ich die möglichkeit gehabt hätte
mehr freiheiten zu haben ohne mich
impfen zu lassen
hätte ich abgewartet ob es vielleicht
noch an vielleicht ein anderer impfstoff
auf dem markt raus kommt die
nebenwirkung vielleicht noch ein
bisschen was angeschaut jeder hat ein
info angebot bekommen und wer das jetzt
aus welchen gründen nicht wahrnimmt der
ist selber schuld wenn er erkrankt oder
ähnliches so würde ich die sache
formulieren es wird etwas anders gemacht
die gesellschaft wird gespalten und
dass das wird noch ein schwieriges thema
auch im herbst werden man darf wenn die
leute von einfach was wirklich überzeugt
sind dass nicht unterschätzt
ich finde mittlerweile braucht man gar
keine wahlplakate wäre ich sage die
wahlen spielen sich nur noch in den
sozialen medien statt also
da gilt ist total aktiv zu sein da total
mitzumachen mitzureden ich finde es
unheimlich belastet auch soziale
netzwerke finde ich super schwierig
dafür um sich eine
politische meinung zu bilden wir sind
halt alle total oberflächlich
mittlerweile auch durch social media
letztendlich und ja es wird auf den
kandidaten rumgehackt obwohl wir ja gar
nicht die kandidaten wählen eigentlich
müssten die wahlprogramme im vordergrund
stehen ich glaub in meiner generation
ist es normal dass man eher digital
unterwegs ist als dass man sich eine
zeitung oder eine zeitschrift kraft ich
persönlich bin sehr tief weil es für
katrin ich lese auch zeichnungen also
ich habe zum beispiel in faz und new
york times abo also zeit und liebe ich
nicht
ich schaue mir auf instagram oder
natürlich
nachrichten im fernsehen
klar man schon auch gerne in die bild
aber dann auch so was wie instagram
facebook ist ab und so schwierig dass
natürlich auch viele falschaussagen
kommentaren gibt einige dazu stellung
nehmen und dann wieder diskussionen auch
ich krieg natürlich viel kritik ab das
sind ziemlich häufig ziemlich miese
spinner drunter und
machen einen ganz schönen schlechte
laune mit den sachen die da kommentieren
und von sich geben auch der
kommunikationsstil also da werden
jegliche hemmschwellen abgelegt unter
wird beschimpft und beleidigt und das
ist echt ein wahnsinniges problem der
sozialen medien sie lösen so ein
bisschen die die medien ab die früher
zur orientierung der menschen galten
meine intention hierbei der phönixstraße
mitzumachen war ja letztendlich leuten
politik ein bisschen näher zu bringen
die vielleicht halt gerade nicht so viel
damit zu tun haben und die sehe ich dann
eher auf instagram als auf
als abonnenten der welt oder irgendwie
so
[Musik]
im august kam dann der punkt an dem man
erkannt hat dass kann alles auch ganz
anders laufen als man die ganzen monate
immer gedacht hat da waren dann zum
ersten mal gefühlt seit jahrzehnten cdu
und spd gleichauf die anderen verteilen
sind so ungefähr gleich geblieben aber
da war klar es könnte auch eine die eben
geben ohne die union
diesen aufregung weil die grünen im
landtag tempo 30 irgendwie vorgeschlagen
hatten und dann hatte ich gesagt ich
verstehe mich weil du kommst doch immer
noch von a nach b du kannst du deine
karre dafür nehmen und kriegs bessere
luft dafür also das doch eine win win
situation eigentlich
mein background mein vater war lehrer
meine mutter hausfrau meine mutter war
französin ich bin auch deutsch
französischer beiden nationalitäten aber
ursprünglich bin ich sahen darin und mit
einer zwischenstation in köln und in
australien habe ich auch gelebt und
20.10 bin ich dann nach essen gekommen
und war wissenschaftliche mitarbeiterin
an der uni und so aber jetzt habe ich
mich ganz bewusst dazu entschieden
aktivistinnen zu sein klima aktivisten
seit jetzt vier jahren mich nervt
besonders die angstkultur die angst vor
veränderung besonders in der politik und
in der wirtschaft die größte
herausforderung einer generation ist für
mich persönlich definitiv die klimakrise
und der erhalt und die weiterentwicklung
der demokratie
ich kann als ingenieur nicht
nachvollziehen wenn ich langsamer fahre
und länger fahre dass ich weniger
ausstoßen nämlich schneller bin das ist
unterm strich sicherlich eine
milchmädchenrechnung ich glaube es geht
um das liebste kind der deutschen dass
das auto an und da fühlen sich viele
halt in ihrer ehre oder irgendwo keine
ahnung ich verstehe auch leute nicht die
ein auto mit 230 ps haben müssen oder so
also das ist aber ich bin ehrlich ich
hab auch keine nutzen und 30 uhr
zurückkam es tut mir leid ich recht zur
arbeit fahre ich immer durch mülheim
durch duisburg dann ist es schon stück
weil ich da überall mit 30 und
weißer weiter weg klimaschutz
klimawandel hin und her aber ich glaube
kann auch noch andere sache tun wir
haben das sind seine vorschläge
tempolimit ist eine pseudo diskussion
ich fahre auch viel auto
durchschnitts verkehr läuft bei 120 im
ruhrgebiet sogar noch weitaus darunter
und wir haben ich weiß gar nicht wie
viel prozent der strecken acht oder zehn
oder 15 prozent sind überhaupt nur
freigegeben um schnell zu fahren es ist
ein thema was viel zu sehr aufgeblasen
wird man kann lieber über andere sachen
diskutieren also auf autobahnen finde
ich sollte mich am längsten tempolimit
lahm ich finde autofahren in holland zum
beispiel total angenehm da kommt nicht
von hinten damit 240 an und bringt dich
weg man kommt auch von a nach b
niederlande da ist man ja auch schnell
durchs ganze land so ist halt ein
kleines land und wenn man hier von
von hier nach berlin fährt oder von
hamburg nach münchen ist es vielleicht
auch mal was anderes wir haben ja eh
ständig staub wir haben ja nicht die
besten autobahn an vielen stellen das
für gefährlich ein tempolimit von 120
oder 130 absolut umsetzbar nee ist nicht
schön auf autobahnen warum wo ist der
sinn jahr co2 ausstoß hin oder her aber
ich glaube nicht dass es so viele
ausmacht ich glaube da gibt es jetzt
ganz andere andere klimasünder also beim
tempolimit finde ich also dass das würde
ich jetzt mal von dieser klimadiskussion
abkoppeln da gibt es klipp und klar
darum dass mehr leute überleben würden
dass wir einen sicheren verkehr hätten
ich finde solche diskussionen absurd ich
finde sowas könnte so einfach
beschlossen werden dann regt sich die
ganze nation zwei monate darüber auf und
dann würde alles normal funktionieren
ich möchte die feuerwehr im schnitt
sofort selbst will ich's nicht mache
aber das ist schon krass also wenn das
dann in seiner persönlichen freiheit
einschränkt dann sieht man ja schnelles
autofahren als teil der eigenen
persönlichkeit und das ist ja schon sehr
seltsam also ich würde mich doch nicht
über schnelles auto also wenn ich jetzt
meine mit 200 sachen über die autobahn
brettern zu müssen ungefährlich alle
leute um mich herum und es gibt ein
begriff dafür dass man sich nicht sage
ich mal so verhält dass man die die
allgemeinheit berücksichtigt und das
bedeutet asozial ist es auch bei der alv
den ideologien unterm strich realistisch
bringt so oder so nichts was ist
eigentlich schon umgesetzt ja durch die
ganzen geschwindigkeitsbegrenzung die
eigentlich vorhanden sind
wir sind dann nach essen in die stadt
gefahren wenn man haben werbung gemacht
für die wallstraße
bzw für die wahl an sich dass die leute
am 26 september auch hingehen oder eben
briefwahl
[Musik]
ja ich bin für die briefwahl gerade in
zeiten von corona weil ich mir dadurch
erhoffe dass mehr menschen sich an der
wahl beteiligen ja ich bin also ganz
klar gegen die briefwahl weil der
manipulation dadurch tür und tor
geöffnet sind und ich finde es auch
traditionell ganz gut wenn man mal
ordentlich sonntags in das wahllokal
geht ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
man gegen briefwahl sein kann wir sind
ja nicht im tram plant ne-yo hat
wissen wir nicht
wissen würde ich vertrauen ist gut
kontrolle ist besser
kann man gegen sein muss man darüber
nicht muss aber
mir fehlt die phantasie tatsächlich um
die probleme bei einer briefwahl zu
sehen ach
ja
für die union kannten die umfragen dann
über eine längere zeit nur eine richtung
nämlich abwärts und gleichzeitig für die
spd steil nach oben deshalb war dann im
september umfrage technisch alles anders
als bisher also so spannend war
wahlkampf in deutschland schon lange
nicht mehr weil ja alles möglich ist da
muss man gucken was ich zum beispiel
durch die trails noch kurzfristig ändert
guten abend liebe zuschauer herzlich
willkommen zum dreikampf der
spitzenkandidaten bei ard und zdf wir
sind jetzt kurz vor
leider fällt schon das studio zusammen
also einen koffer um geschwister oder
zumindest gut reagiert wie ist gerade
hier rumpelt im studio so spannend wird
diese bundestags
[Musik]
wir haben in den 90er jahren viele
experten experten gehört die haben uns
erzählt das wird alles nichts werden mit
der rente das klappt alles nicht mehr
sie haben uns für diese zeit vorher
gesagt dass wir sehr hohe beiträge
zahlen werden sie haben uns auch gesagt
dass wir viel weniger arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmer haben werden das gegenteil
ist eingetreten sie können nicht einem
der heute in das berufsleben einsteigt
sagen es wird alles so bleiben wie es
ist dieses weiter so wird uns da nicht
helfen wir müssen doch jetzt dafür
sorgen dass wir das rentenniveau
stabilisieren und das allererste ist und
das wollen sie nicht und deswegen haben
wir ein problem fachkräfte zuwanderung
wir sind ein einwanderungsland wenn wir
die menschen die hier leben allen
ermöglichen auch zu arbeiten dann fallen
sie in die sozialversicherungssysteme
wirklich mit ein
[Musik]
berbalk ist die einzige opposition ich
kann daran aber ebenso wird es schon
gewesen die auf die anderen kandidaten
drauf geklappt hat sondern sie hat ganz
konkrete vorschläge ganz konkrete
maßnahmen die sie angehen will
dargestellt aber de facto ist es so dass
zum beispiel auch die vorschläge von
annalena baerbock ein guter anfang waren
leider hätten sie beispielsweise meine
rente trotzdem nicht und die fdp hat ein
klares finanzierungssystem dafür
und alle anderen parteien leider nicht
nur wenn das rentenkonzept erste person
ist ein kind das dann kann oder warum
adaptieren die das nicht anders das hat
herr schweiz letztlich bei der wahlarena
versucht mehr oder minder leicht
abgeschwächt ich denke auch wenn es zu
einer koalition kommen wir dann wird man
irgendwo mittel wir gehen in sachen
arbeiten bis jahre
irgendwie mindestlohn jahr dafür aber
beispielsweise und unser rentenkonzept
also herr scholz hat das ein wenig
verein hat schon versucht es ist einfach
so der klassische dreisatz gibt egal
welche das konzept einfach nicht mehr
her wir sind die geburtenstarken
jahrgänge anfang 60 er jahre gehöre ich
zu ihr müsst das alles finanzieren das
geht nicht die die beiträge sind zu hoch
mit ihm geht auch das wird sehr sehr
schwer werden das wie gibt es auch hier
auch in der blauen partei dazu habe ich
ja den kollegen da angeschossen keine
richtige antwort ja gebe ich jetzt so es
gibt dazu keine
tragfähige antwort mir fällt auch kanal
es ist ja de facto so dass wir einen
fachkräftemangel haben und entweder
entweder sein ausleihen
dass wir fachkräfte brauchen dass wir
zuwanderung brauchen unter anderem auch
um unser demografieproblem irgendwie
ich wenig sagen in den griff zu kriegen
aber um dadurch auch die renten
finanzieren zu können oder man man sieht
ist halt einfach nicht einfach den bogen
pauschalen wehrleute halte ich für nicht
nicht einfach machen dass die
vermischung mit asyl und qualifizierter
zuwanderung ist auch nicht rechtens da
geht man da überhaupt nichts zu tun da
ist wichtig gibt es ein gesetz für und
wir haben leider kein gesetz für eine
qualifizierte zuwanderung kein mensch
der hier arbeiten will mit einem gesetz
bewerben wie es in anderen ländern was
ich kann ja da gibt es diese ganze
geschichte und er macht eine bewerbung
und er wird wieder aufgenommen da kann
arbeiten gibt es nicht ich glaub ich
glaube dieses thema rente ist 1 wo man
als politiker auch nur verlieren kann
wenn man da die wahrheit sagt weil ich
glaub ich finde es schon mal zum andreas
gehe ich glaube als adenauer damals
dieses generationen ding schon
eingeführt hat wusste man eigentlich
schon zum scheitern verurteilt aber da
ganz klar
lösung angeboten
unzureichende aber immerhin anfangen und
der offene schlagabtausch war früher
etwas knackiger war der hat mir
eigentlich gefehlt dazu alle sieht oft
konsens bedacht gewesen und das hat
eigentlich hat so ein bisschen wie sagt
eva gefehlt das hängt auch mit den
kandidaten ich meine die haben jetzt
alle drei nicht das charisma wo man
sagen würde ja auch die wesentliche zwar
stimmt es auch ganz klar
also wir uns gerade hier das trial
gemeinsam angeguckt was sie machen einen
finde ist dass viele fragen leider etwas
ausgewiesen wurde
sie habe ich hallo also ich fand es auch
sehr sehr interessant würde aber dieser
in den punkt widersprechen ich fand die
grünen haben nämlich klare vorschläge
gemacht und ich fand dass das
themenspektrum
abgedeckt wurde wirklich sehr umfassend
ich fand das tri l auch sehr interessant
ich finde es nur schade ich bin der
meinung wenn die grünen mittlerweile bei
15 prozent sind und die fdp bei 13 ist
es nicht mehr zu rechtfertigen dann
nicht den liberalen spitzenkandidaten
einzuladen
ich kann ihm nur zustimmen
das trio war sehr interessant denn noch
habe ich gedacht der armen wird noch ein
bisschen fetziger
ja dem kann ich mich nur anschließen
weil es letzten endes ja ein trial
bedeutet dass man sich abgrenzt
voneinander und ich war aus sicht kann
man so nicht sagen entspannter bei
dieser veranstaltung hat festgestellt
hat sie sich gar nicht richtig gemacht
haben wir haben einen auf konsens
gemacht und dann verstehe ich nicht weil
es sollten ja die unterschiedlichen
standpunkte herausgearbeitet werden und
das habe ich nicht gesehen grundsätzlich
war es ein spannendes ereignis
es wurde viel gesagt wo wenig warum kam
und wir schauen einfach mal was dann bei
der rat entschieden wird
[Musik]